So, let me tell you about two technical terms.
One called recall, one is called precision.
These are the terms for what you just computed.
For example, the recall rate on Hugo Chavez is the quotient of how many,
is the probability of our algorithm to correctly identify Hugo Chavez,
provided that the person actually is Hugo Chavez.
So in our case, it was 10 over 16.
Precision of the same concept would be the rate of which the rate of
which if our algorithm predicted would be the second rate that we studied,
which happened to be one.
It's the quotient of, suppose our algorithm observes that there's Hugo Chavez,
what are the chances that it actually is Hugo Chavez and
it happened to be 10 over 10?